cet adolescent est hébergé dans un
centre jeunesse de montréal pour lui
ramasser les feuilles mortes est une
bonne action
une bonne action c'est quelque chose que
tout le monde peut faire ça peut être
n'importe quoi il ya plusieurs choses
qu'on peut faire raclée des feuilles pas
symbole et une mop aider quelqu'un à
faire quelque chose
ouais en retour on lui permet de se
choisir des vêtements à son goût des
vêtements qu'il choisit à cet endroit
vous êtes dans mon grenier comme on peut
dire les greniers de leur reine offre
des vêtements et accessoires neufs ou
usagés aux enfants qui reçoivent les
services de la direction de la
protection de la jeunesse de montréal
c'est pas tout le monde qui aime les
moyens de se payer du linge donc si je
trouve que c'est vraiment accessible
pour tous
mais les jeunes doivent s'engager à
rendre service et l'inscrire sur une
étoile je m'engage à faire une brassée
de linge d'amener les assiettes
elle a avisé les plantes sa porte
l'estiment de soi ça apporte aussi que
les jeunes ils sont plus organisés ils
sont capables de s'engager là souvent un
jeune exemple qui est un hébergement et
souvent réfractaires c'est difficile on
est dans le pot ce tir sept autres
adolescents lui a accompli une dizaine
de tâches c'est comme de nos supports
après vaud et de leur prochain parce
qu'ils y ont été aidées la dpj
accompagne quinze mille jeunes à
montréal
certains viennent d'un milieu familial
difficile d'autres présentent des
troubles de comportement lorraine estime
qu'ensemble ils réalisent une bonne
action chaque année se donne ton temps
puisque ses fans
ces adolescents ont découvert que donner
au suivant pouvait aussi être payant et
amusant ici marie laurence de l'aîné
radio canada montréal